I drink a lot of coffee and wine I feel
like those are important things in my
life like I need them I feel like coffee
and wine are like my life coaches
coffees there for a pat on the ass like
go get them we can do this and then ones
like you'll get them tomorrow you gave
it a good shot
keep your chin up like thanks why you're
the only one who gets me I like
classical radio stations they're so
peaceful you know the DJ's are so
soft-spoken
they'll take like these really long
pauses after the song ends almost like
they're afraid to speak bum bum bum
[Music]
in G flat major I gotta be so creepy
about it just play the next song and
make me feel so dirty
maybe we tell you the key signature to
is always part of the title like we're
not trying to play along at home a flat
minor I was so close mmm an excellent
choice look big I don't like when people
tell me that their baby is flirting with
me
like a baby will smile at me and the
parents that go
she's such a flirt I don't know how to
tell you this but I'm not attracted to
your baby I feel like it's inappropriate
of them to even suggest that because
what if I was to be like you know I'm so
glad you said that because I thought
your baby was flirting with me I was
like am I crazy is this baby into me so
thank you for the green light with your
baby it is on baby style I think what
they're actually saying is I hope my
baby is heterosexual because if a boy
baby was smiling at me they would be
like well looks like we got a gay baby
I'm sure he's not just smiling no he's
gay fair enough it is fun to do the gay
voice though you know like seriously
whatever I should say stereotypically
flamboyant gay boys not all gay people
talk like that unfortunately but there
is something fun about it liberating
even because for straight guys we have a
very limited range of emotion that we're
allowed to show we always have to keep
things so bland and boring like all
right I'll see you at 6 and bring the
files I'll see you there okay guys like
you better be there
so jealous gay people have their own
flag of course the rainbow flag
nobody ever burns that flag though that
wouldn't be much of a protest to see a
flaming gay flag it's more of a show of
support really sometimes people will
profess to be supportive of gay rights
or gay marriage but they do it in a way
that doesn't really sound supportive
it'll be like it who cares just marry
whoever you want I don't need to know
who cares that's not really supportive
have you ever gone to a wedding and
given the bride and groom a card that
says who cares they're human beings it's
an important day maybe you should care
maybe caring is more supportive I don't
even like the term sexual preference I
don't think it's accurate language I
don't think it's a preference like I
prefer direct flights but if there's a
layover I'll still take the flight if I
booked a flight to vagina and there's a
layover in man's ass
I'm canceling the trip good night
everybody thank you so much